well it's easier to predict who the
losers are then who the winners are the
losers are ones speaking of media
specifically hard dependent upon an
advertising model and a pure
subscription model where people are
simply paying for the media content and
that is a very difficult model as we
transition increasingly rapidly from
print you know over-the-air to online
because that's no great observation but
people just aren't prepared to pay as
much for online so what you we look at
you need to have multiple streams of
income some of which are not dependent
upon those traditional sources of media
revenues I think you know content I
believe continues to be absolutely
critical and people are willing to pay
for real insight through a period like
this the notion of just pure aggregation
I think over time is a less successful
model than creating real content of
value but you have to be able to
distribute it in a way and therefore the
distributor's the networks themselves
willen or enjoy enormous power but we're
a content creator we're also a
distributor and we have multiple streams
and that's why I'm generally very
optimistic about where we're we're
headed
historically most companies have had a
point of view that they needed to create
everything on their own they needed to
build it on their own and I think that
model is essentially breaking down
instead people need to recognize what
they're good at what their core
competencies are and assume hopefully
that there is a core of that that is
powerful enough to sustain a business
model and that fundamentally rely on
others who can have the scale or the
leverage to do it more cheaply and maybe
more efficiently look at newspapers for
example why is it that many newspapers
actually even produce a business section
if you go to say the Chicago Tribune we
actually have more reporters in Chicago
then the Chicago Tribune does why do
they need to produce their own business
section you can apply that across a lot
of different companies a lot of
different pieces of their business it's
the same thing in the financial services
sector many of our customers have built
up enormous infrastructures to
distribute data to manage the flows of
data to process trades etc and they
really are not necessarily in every case
the best party to actually do that where
the function is not creating a
competitive advantage for them so we're
having conversations with a lot of
companies about even creating industry
type utilities that then could be
customizable for that small percentage
of the function that actually creates
competitive advantage and those are
conversations that we're having that we
couldn't have had a couple of years ago
so i think this recognition that you
can't do everything that in fact you
focus on what you're really great at and
are able and willing to in effect
partner or outsource with others to
bring those skills in house that don't
provide the competitive advantage you
need but you still are various
central to the way you do your job your
business I think that is actually a
trend were Singh both on the media side
and on the financial services side